[Musique]
bonjour à tous
si aujourd'hui j'arrive par en bas de
l'écran c'est pour vous parler du cinéma
de djamel avec jamel debbouze quand
c'est sorti fin des années 90 c'était
tellement marrant et bien sûr que ce
soit drôle y avait une recette
elle est très simple vous mettez jamel
et c'est tout limite le fond blanc
derrière ce n'était pas nécessaire peu
importe de quoi ça parlait c'était
marrant pour être drôle il avait les
techniques
la première technique c'était la
technique d eminem ce qui consiste à
mettre les lettres de mnm ce partout
dans une phrase de manière totalement
aléatoire par exemple la phase bonjour
je vais faire un sketch sur le film
scream
ça donnerait bonjour aujourd'hui j'ai
fait un sketch sur krim sa part d'un
serial killer
ça veut dire que quiconque lui croise
qui meurt et jamel tu peux me donner le
nom d'un chanteur français très connu
matthieu chedid sundance et me voyais le
note technique aussi c'est le petit pont
agitateurs la punir autre technique il
se force est même pas à bouger les
lèvres quand il parlait comme s'il
sortait de chez le dentiste
oui et c'est six communes et si la vie
de ces peuples et dire le tourisme aussi
quand il arrivait des fois bah il
courait comme un gamin de 3 ans
saperlipopette sa mère l'époque même
sommaire les poèmes j'ai failli y
rencontrer un brigand un truc que
j'adorais c'est qu'ils se lançaient dans
des phrases qui était un petit peu bien
trop compliqué et ça nous faisait
rigoler parce que les phrases elle
aurait pu être un petit peu plus moins
compliquée qu'elle ne fut cependant
derechef le cinéma jamel c'était aussi
découvrir des talents parce que jamel
invité des potes à lui était pas connue
mais qui était très marrant et toi bien
voir moi se dit d'être la personne des
préférés des français dans vatan ouais
alors regarde la vie bonjour bonjour
merci pour la préférence
merci pour la préférence préféré des
français quand il était tout seul il
était pas vraiment tout seul
ah ouais commença par exemple là tu vois
j'ai pas tout seul à il se dédoublait
mêmes ils ceux des triplets non ils ceux
des tribunes pleines des tribunes
pleines
ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir des fois
il paraît même plus de 6 miles et
dépasse de la charest louis de funès est
bâtard revient
qu'est-ce qu'il ya rien bonjour c'est
juste votre nom jeudi et il n'est pas
tard parce que vous êtes très bien
habillée très joli à une libellule
[Rires]
ça fait plaisir quand j'étais ado je
pétais des câbles sur ses phrases cultes
y en avait plein
dites moi pas qu'c'est pas vrai même si
le directeur de la république est
mesdames et mesdames et dès qu'ils
sortent et un projet il y avait une
fresque hulk allait avec
genre le jah man show la sentence est
irrévocable ça veut dire que même
qu'avec des câbles pour bien faire le
jamel comedy club
le marsupilami je sais qu'il n'existe
astérix mission cléopâtre qui fait boum
au moins 8000 au delà de ça jamel c'est
un mec est sorti de nulle part avec a
tout pété il a poussé influencé toute
une génération de comiques aujourd'hui
nous a montré qu'il y avait moyen assez
comme le dit le grand philosophe jamel
debbouze
si t'as aucune chance alors saisi là et
je vous avoue un truc d'être dans le
même écran que jamel vingt ans plus tard
et ben ça fait plaisir
[Musique]